ich danke der kamera miliz für ihre
treue pflichterfüllung im rahmen der
vierten banziger übrigen mein name ist
major christian horner in der s3 des
panzerbataillons 14 und wo er
federführend verantwortlich für die
planung der waffen übung im rahmen der
herrn berg zahlt sich 19
[Musik]
das besondere an der übung handwerk ist
dass wir den kompletten miliz anteil des
panzerbataillons 14 eingezogen haben und
einberufen haben und wir jetzt gemeinsam
mit den minis kameraden zwei wochen lang
die tätigkeiten in der waffen karton
durchführen mein name ist max ist
meister ich bin aus ried im innkreis
ich bin arzt für allgemeinmedizin und
bin kinder mit tätig als medizin
wachtmeister der miliz magister andreas
kurz taler im zivilen leben bin ich
jurist bei dieser übung bin ich unter
anderem auch für abc agenten zuständig
als kommandant der a b c gruppe namens
martin müller den staatsmeister der
miliz im zivilen bereich bin lehrer an
einer polytechnischen schule in lambach
und über der übung bin ich als fan
gruppen kommandant eingeteilt ich komme
aus dem salzkammergut und bin als major
im augenblick kompaniekommandant der
stabskompanie das waren zur bartel und
ich bin bekannt bei der ersten kompanie
ich komme aus dem raum verantworten und
im süden leben bin ich bei der firma
linde gas beschäftigt
[Musik]
man merkt wie sehr man materie abgebaut
hat über die jahre aber wie schnell über
das wir aber die funktion hineinwächst
aber es ist natürlich schon mal wird aus
dem alltag herausgerissen
wie gesagt es ist eine andere welt und
zum motto haben auch genügend aufgaben
die zu erledigen werden aber für das
offensiv verpflichtet und der
bereicherung
[Musik]
er muss natürlich nur dem label diese
man erreichen gehen wir das eine aber
wir geben unser bestes
wo es gibt in der bergstadt die gut
ausgehen und dann sagst du darfst keine
probleme ist agrana ps oder jugend muss
man dass man was
[Musik]
anna lüth kräuter generell dass man aus
dem alltagstrott heraus kommt wieder
einmal ganz anders sieht heute kann man
trifft immer jahre lange sicht und das
obwohl es ist ja auch so immer wieder
neue kameraden dazu alte gehen weg und
dass die sich kennenlernen können
es ist notwendig dass sie auch brücken
bauen und sich regelmäßig treffen das
panzerbataillon 14
aber natürlich einen hohen präsenz
anteil trotzdem wäre eine 1 satzführung
oder die miliz katamaran so nicht
möglich weil einfach die manpower somit
zu bringen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein
[Musik]
es geht überraschend schnell fast
beängstigend schnell aber ist 24 bis 48
stunden ist man da eigentlich wieder
ziemlich tränen bei mir ist es meistens
dann soweit in einem ersten mal in der
früh wieder tagwache gerufen wird dann
weiß ich wieder wie es losgeht und alles
funktioniert automatisch bis zwei tage
und weiß sozusagen wieder als soldat
voll integriert involviert und den
tagesablauf nimmt man so wie er im
dienstplan stehen wieder zwei jahres
dass ich das gemacht habe
aber es geht doch eigentlich wieder
wo
[Musik]
das lustige haben soldaten leben ist
einfach die gute durchmischung in der
miliz alle dienstgrade und alle privaten
berufe an einem tisch sitzen und
zusätzlich natürlich einmal die
durchmischung mit berufssoldaten
man kann sie sehr für austauschen das
militär auch zivil und gegen gleich
natürlich es ist so dass man sich auf
augenhöhe begegnet und man auch den
eindruck hat dass man als milizionär
trotzdem den stellenwert eines
kadersoldaten hat jetzt schon drinnen es
ist freude tränen wenn miliz personal
auch dann aktiv kader so schön zu sein
mama woche zurückblickt es auch keine
vorfälle gegeben
wir haben einfach gemütlich beisammen
gesessen wären wie hier in meinem fall
und haben die kameradschaft gepflegt
wenn ich beobachte dass also zum
beispiel in der in der feldküche das
überhaupt kein problem ist dass der
soldat der miliz aus dem zivilen leben
kommen sofort genauso an den kochtöpfen
steht wie jeder andere
das natürlich dazu gang eines
milizsoldaten oft ein anderer ist und
teilweise unkonventionellen wir sind
doch recht festgefahren in unsere
strukturen und problem
lösungsmechanismen um die bringen durch
neue aspekte und sichtweisen herein und
da kann man doch wirklich auch davon
profitieren
[Musik]
mein name ist dass leute und läutet ich
bin kommandant des panzerbataillons 14
das fahrzeug 14 ist das panzerbataillon
des heeres und der kern mit einem 7
landesverteidigung
über 48 grad weiter und diese sind
inzwischen drei komponenten gegliedert
[Musik]
die aufgabe der panzer mache ist es im
zuge der militärischen
landesverteidigung sowohl in der
verteidigung als auch im angriff schwere
flach vor ihrer unterstützung für die
grenadiere verbände sicherzustellen und
selbstständig im panzer gewährende
anzugreifen und feind zu werfen weil
unser handwerk geht es den wahn 42 vor
allem darum seinen soldaten gemeinsam
mit den kartendaten verstärkt durch die
grundwehrdiener in der militärischen
landesverteidigung zur schule
dafür haben wir einen kampfpanzer
company gegliedert die angriffs weise
vorgeht und damit die weitere bewegung
der brigade sicherstellt angefangen wird
das wirklich eine ordentliche
öffentlichkeitsarbeit gemacht wird ja
das war wirklich versucht das was hier
gelebt wird da kann man viel auch
wiederum ins private leben mitnehmen an
die öffentlichkeit getragen wird weil
man oft den eindruck dass viele personen
im näheren umkreis gar nicht wissen was
da eigentlich geschieht was da passiert
und dass es auch sehr interessante
tätigkeiten sind
[Musik]
ja ich möchte mich bei den kameraden der
miliz bedanken für ihr engagement für
die teilnahme an der übung handwerk sie
waren ein wesentlicher teil in der
erlernung und vertiefung der gefechts
technik die wir hier einen steig
durchgeführt haben und ich würde mir
wünschen dass dieses engagement auch in
zukunft beibehalten wird
[Musik]
und unten
wir werden aufgelöst auch gleich
komplett
[Musik]
und mitten in der stadt
ausgelöst durch mich nach meinen lesen
sollen
das bereits prima wetter
der bund
[Musik]
im alltag ein
feuer
die kameraden das war die miliz übung
handwerk 2009/10 wir sagen danke an alle
die mitgewirkt haben
christian wird uns jetzt zahlen daten
fakten nur übers öffentlichkeitsarbeit
team nennen nicht im privaten leben
betreiben wir eine große media video
agenturen fernsehsender und davon haben
wir fünf kameras eine drohne und zwar
schnitt computer mitgenommen auf die
übung und wo die video sitzen sehen
werdet sagt uns ist unser kommandant die
videos findet ihr unter facebook und
youtube
wir würden uns freuen wenn es diese
videos likes und auch teils und
weiterhin treu der mensch steckt bleibt